I'm gonna teach a strategy right now
that will change your life it's called
the 2% difference the next time you're
feeling down frustrated depressed angry
tell yourself it's the best
entrepreneurs generally don't have a lot
of patience and that's actually a good
thing one of the biggest things that
holds entrepreneurs back the motivation
watch a top 10 with believe nation
I'm Evan Carmichael and here's my take
on my top ten roses success volume six
enjoy okay let's take it off with rule
number one take action now I'm going to
teach a strategy right now that will
change your life it's called the two
percent difference
the two percent difference is as soon as
you get an idea for something as soon as
you get an idea for a new thing that you
want to try out you go do it and it's
called the two percent difference
because most people when they come up
with an idea what they do is they think
about it they plan they strategize right
you got an idea to go launch something
great you go home you strategize you you
think are you playing you think about it
but then you wake up tomorrow a
different person you wake up tomorrow a
different person you are feeling bold
yesterday you can with this great bold
bold vision for yourself amazing you're
feeling on top of the world yesterday
you wake up tomorrow a different person
and then you don't do anything about it
maybe we research a little bit more and
then that idea is dead I believe that
the decisions that you make when you're
feeling bold unstoppable and confident
are actually the right ones for you and
then your head talked to you down from
doing them we just don't live in the
land of bold and confidence 24/7 we
spend 1% of our life
if that feeling bold and confident and
the other 90 nothing feeling scared and
afraid and back down to where we were
before so the decisions you make when
you're feeling bold and confident are
the right ones for you and therefore the
first step you need to take is not
planning is not strategizing is not
thinking it's action the 2% difference
what that means is instead of going home
and strategizing and planning on how to
get to a hundred percent of your goal
build immediate momentum I how to get
the two percent of your goal focus on
taking action to get 2% of the way close
to hitting your goal and then that
momentum will carry you forward to
helping you get through to the rest of
the hundred so here's an example I'm
filming this from Las Vegas I'm on this
tour right now I promised Nina I made a
decision I'm gonna take me in at every
city in North America with a million
plus people that was the goal that I had
great most people would go home start
researching thinking how many cities are
there in North America with a million
plus people how
we're gonna do it nina has a full-time
job on and on and on and on with all the
reasons why you're not gonna be able to
do it you start planning and
strategizing great no that's not the way
to do it because you wake up tomorrow
different persons say I don't know about
that goal I can I can't do that
and you start talking yourself down from
it so while you're feeling the boldness
of it when you're feeling capable when
you actually feel capable of
accomplishing that goal you go off and
you do something so I said great this
weekend I'm gonna go to Boston
Nina had never been to Boston so this
weekend we're gonna go to Boston and I
message heard to say Nina I've decided
I'm gonna take it every city in North
America with a million-plus people and
this weekend we're gonna go to Boston
turns out those 50 cities on the list I
don't know how I'm gonna get to my 50
cities yet but I can hit one and that's
2% if you cannot get to the first 2%
immediately you will never get to the 50
you'll never get to the hundred this is
never gonna happen
this is the problem for most
entrepreneurs you plan too much you
strategize too much you think too much
you're too smart we're smart and so you
find really smart reasons why you can't
do something you're a perfectionist
you're worried about putting something
out before it's ready and then you never
release it the people who have met on
this tour I feel so bad for them i but
it blows my mind of people who've waited
decades plus to move forward on their
idea that idea that you have that you're
sitting on you need so you'll do
something about it right now
that's the difference there are dummies
dummies dummies who are winning in your
industry who don't have as much
intellect as you who don't have as much
passion as you who don't have as much of
a heart and a cause of wanting to do
something good to serve as you do and
they're winning and you're not why
because they're actually off doing the
work and you're sitting on your couch at
home strategize and researching planning
thinking about it and being too afraid
to go off and take action and so the 2%
difference the next time you feel
yourself coming up with an idea when we
get ideas all the time you get an idea
train yourself idea trusted it comes
from somewhere right that idea comes
from somewhere don't judge it don't be
critical of it it came from somewhere
you have a responsibility to do
something about it idea to action idea
the action train yourself idea to action
it's always something today use a lot of
something in the shower great idea do
something I did
action the 2% difference stop planning
your way on how to get to a hundred
percent of your goal and figure out what
can you do right now today immediately
to get 2% of the way start applying that
principle it will change your life
rule number two change your mindset I'm
gonna give you the most important
strategy that the next time you're
feeling frustrated you're feeling
defeated you're feeling like giving up
will save you and help you find that
inner strength and next gear here it is
tell yourself it's the best the next
time you're feeling down frustrated
depressed angry tell yourself it's the
best because now this is your chance to
show yourself and the world what you're
made of
the next time you're stuck at a red
light and you're frustrated complaining
it's the best the next time you're
working out and you feel like you're on
your last scent your your lungs are on
fire and you can't push again it's the
best the next time you're frustrated in
business that you're not getting the
sales you need and you feel like you're
waking up every day and there's no
momentum it's the best it's the best
this is your chance this is your chance
you can complain for seven and a half
seconds and get frustrated and then
tweak it inside your brain to say this
is the best why what does it do first
it switches your mindset to one of
hopelessness to one of resourcefulness
it switches your mindset from one of
hopelessness that this sucks that I'm
giving up I'm defeated it's over why
does this happen to me why does this
suck to whine of resourcefulness that
this is the best this is my chance
because you grow through challenges and
this is the next challenge in front of
me that I am going to grow through rule
number three change your perspective
most entrepreneurs can't handle a major
setback you can't you can handle a whole
bunch of little setbacks a little bit of
punch to the face but you can't handle a
major setback when there's a major
meltdown what do you do to get back up
you find another way or do you quit and
most entrepreneurs most businesses will
quit look at how many companies are
still around look at the biggest
companies in the world how many of them
were around the hundred years ago
not very many most companies go out of
business because they can adjust it
can't evolve they don't love the dark
clouds enough let's look at YouTube as
an example whenever there's a major
algorithm change
everybody's upset everybody's
complaining everybody is freaking out
like I don't like it I don't like it
right they complain I get pumped I get
pumped because it's my chance to win now
it's sucks because it's a lot of work
because you got to figure out a new path
but everybody who's ahead of you who's
complaining that's your chance to win
and so I'm going through right now I
look at my channel and making three
videos a day might be a setback for my
channel even in this video I don't know
where it's gonna be it might be on my
main channel might be on a sub channel
that I'm making it's a big potential
strategic shift for me to say going from
one channel to three or eight haven't
fully figured it out yet but I'm pumped
I'm pumped while other people are
suffering and struggling and complaining
that this is the new YouTube I'm gonna
test it out immediate action let's go
it's not that loving the dark clouds at
least for me it's not that loving the
dark clouds you want negativity to
happen you want it to be controversial
you want chaos to happen you want your
competitors go out of business you want
it to be difficult it's not that it's
that that's your chance to win and so
the best thing I recommend is flip it in
your head
learn to tell yourself that this is the
best when everybody else is complaining
when everybody else is struggling even
when you when you put all this work into
doing something and now it's collapsing
on you it's really hard to stay positive
tell yourself this is the best this is
my opportunity to prove to myself in the
world what I'm made of and then if you
can move from a place of resourceless
'no story source fulness and find a path
while everybody else is ahead of you in
complaining that's your chance to win
rule number four be patient
entrepreneurs generally don't have a lot
of patience and that's actually a good
thing we want things now we want to
hustle hard we want to see the results
of our labor paying off we want to see
you know change happening we have a big
vision we know it can work and we want
it to happen right now and that's that's
that's amazing I want you to hold on to
it
and
the same time I want you to have
incredible patience because what ends up
happening is entrepreneurs often quit
too soon you had the right idea you had
the right vision you even had the right
execution certain it up but you just
quit you thought I was gonna happen in
three months where it's actually gonna
happen in three years for what you're
doing every single day
you need to be applying yourself a
closed-off every other opportunity for
four years and then you'll be successful
four years ago on my youtube channel I
had 7,000 ish subscribers four years ago
how did I get here with 1.2 million by
making videos every single day every
single day I we haven't missed a day in
four years and in the past two or three
years has been three times a day or at
least two times a day just grinding it
out and in those little micro moments in
those micro videos it's super impatience
right it's like this video has to
deliver this video not have to deliver
this next one this one right here has to
deliver there's a lot of impatience to
make things happen and it's knowing that
this is gonna take me years to get to
where I want to go also if you want to
learn how to build more confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series it's
free and the link is in the description
below if you're doing work that you
loved you're more likely to follow
through you're more likely to do it
because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it
surround yourself with greatness if you
want to be more confident you need to
surround yourself with things that make
you feel confident rule number five live
your truth most people aren't happy in
life because they're living somebody
else's truth you're not living your
truth you're living somebody else's
version of it your parents your family
your culture your society you live in
somebody else's version of it and so
you're never happy because you never
explored it you never picked at it you
never found out what you could be and
you settle for something less than what
you're capable of you know you're
capable of more you may not know what
the thing is that you should be doing
but you know it's not this thing right
in front of you I can't tell you how
many people I've met on this tour who
have that story to share I had a woman
whose father told her that women should
not be doing any kind of Ontario
ventures
women are meant to be teachers and so
she spent 15 years being a teacher
before having a courage to jump off and
start her own business
and now she has a multi-million dollar
construction business I had a girl come
up in Albuquerque where I am right now
who studied for years to be an
accountant why because her mom was
accountant so her mom made her go
studied to become an accountant she
didn't know what she wanted to do so she
said okay great yeah I'll be an
accountant she just graduated and
realized I don't want to be an
accountant this isn't for me it's easy
it's the path that my parents took like
it's great for me to get into it I can
get easy money you know my mom said I'll
like it when the money starts coming in
but money's coming in and I don't like
it I want to do something else I know
I'm meant for something greater and so
she told her mom I don't want to do this
I want to learn how to be a management
consultant am I gonna go back to school
that takes a lot of guts that takes a
lot of courage most people do not have
that courage most people do not have the
courage to stand up to their parents and
say I don't want this life
it doesn't mean you have to hate them
you have to attack them you have to tell
them they're wrong this is for you you
don't want that life most people never
have that courage and the story that
comes to mind for me is acteal Mehta and
use this as motivation as wisdom if you
are trying to battle your parents or
your culture your friends your society
remember Akio Morita he started Sony now
he came from 11 or 12 generations of
sake Brewers Japanese background the
Japanese culture is super
family-oriented and the oldest always
takes over the family business all this
has to follow in line with what the
family was doing and so he was expected
to take over the sake business and it's
not just one generation you're talking
11 to 12 generations in a Japanese
society and he said I don't want to do
this I want to start my own business a
technology company at a time when Japan
was known for super low quality products
this is the man who put Japan on the map
for high quality products that products
coming out of Japan meant something was
a stamp of quality because of Akio
Morita and he went on to build one of
the most successful brands in the world
and Sony but it starts with having the
courage having a courage to say that's
not my
that's not my truce rule number six
surround yourself with greatness this is
why I keep going with my YouTube channel
this is the reason why I keep going with
my youtube channel because yes your
spouse is important and yes your friend
is important and the people that you
hang out with our super super super
important and all the other people that
you hang out with by reading books and
consuming content watching videos all of
that makes an impact to the more that
you spend hanging around people and
ideas and wisdom that bring you up the
more you're going to rise up and the
more you're around people who are
complaining and negative and pulling you
down guess what happens the more you're
gonna be pulled down and one of the big
reasons for me in creating this channel
was I wanted to be around successful
entrepreneurs I wanted to be around
people who would push me to go off and
do more because in my life I'm super
fortunate to have a very understanding
wife a very supportive family friends
who encouraged me and you know always
support the things that I'm doing but I
don't have people who are pushing me to
do better you know I don't have people
who say you know what what you're doing
is great but you should be out here like
you could be making these adjustments
and playing a bigger game you can have a
bigger impact and so I needed more of
that in my life
and so my solution defining it was was
the videos was I want to hang her on
Elon Musk and I want to hang around
Steve Jobs don't want to hang around
Warren Buffett I want to hang around
these people we're thinking on a bigger
scale because the more you do that the
more you ingest this content the more
you're gonna think like them the more
you're gonna act like them the more
you're gonna take these pieces to not
only just be like them but to be the
best version of you rule number seven
don't try to please everybody
so listen everybody's gonna have an
opinion on what you should do with your
life everybody your your friends your
family your culture your society your
community your customers online haters
everybody's got an opinion on what you
should do with your life and it's
tempting to want to take the advice one
because it gives us advice but two it
does also somebody to blame right like
if it doesn't work out it's not my fault
is that person's fault they said I
should do it
some point though you have to decide
that you are gonna be an adult that you
are in control that you want to go off
and build your own life and you only you
know what that looks like and you have
to have the courage to the confidence to
step up and say I'm in charge this is my
life now I get to decide what I want to
do and some opinions will matter and
some opinions will make a difference and
others you have to let bounce off you
you're not gonna be able to please
everybody everybody has an opinion on
what you should do with your life and
the only one that really matters truly
is this one right here so how do you
decide how do you know what the
difference is how do you know which
opinions you should take which you
should listen to because on the one hand
it's you want to take advice you want to
take counsel you don't know everything
and on the other hand it's it's your
life you gotta decide how do you make
those two things work together
number one is understand what your one
word is your one word is the most
important core value mine is believe
yours is whatever it is it's worth going
through the exercise I think is one of
the most important exercise you can ever
do in your life it becomes a filter
through which you see the world and so
for me it's belief and believe is around
believing in yourself having
self-confidence believing in the work
that you're doing having passion for it
and believing that it's gonna work out
believe it in the impact believing that
there is light at the end of the tunnel
even if you only see darkness around you
right now
that's believe and so all of the
decisions that I make are through the
lens of believe every new piece of
content and I put on my channel is
through the lens of belief and so if you
give me advice that has nothing to do it
believe it may be great potential advice
but it's not for me how do I know what's
for me because I'm sitting on my rock of
belief and if you don't know what value
you stand on it's easy to get pulled in
a lot of different directions rule
number eight ain't consistent most
hunters don't win because they're not
consistent at us it's not because you
don't have talent or skills or energy
you're just not consistent enough you're
not consistent enough too many
entrepreneurs get all pumped up and
motivated and you're working like crazy
and you have an amazing day and then the
next day you wake up and you're back to
your normal life and you're not
consistently putting in the effort the
reason why my youtube channel has one is
because I made videos every single day
for four five years five years ago plus
I had seven thousand subscribers on my
youtube channel now we're over 1.8
million not because I'm super talented
I'm not go back watch some videos you'll
see how I suck
the beginning super-nervous awkward in a
suit sitting down just terrible but by
making videos every single day I got
better and I was able to conquer what I
didn't have any natural talent in
because I learned to develop the skill
by beating on my craft every single day
and so this is one of the major problems
for entrepreneurs I think a lot of
people could have done what I've done I
think a lot of you watching you could
have done what I've done you have more
natural talent than I do the difference
is I got up every day for five years and
did it and so I don't think it's that
special I think it's just putting in the
effort in the hustle every single day
and that's a big reason why so many
entrepreneurs don't win you are just not
consistent enough in your effort rule
number nine find your genius I like to
say that everybody has Michael Jordan
level talent is something I believe it I
think I think you have Michael Jordan
level talent or something I think your
genius a legit bona fide genius
you should be off there change in the
world I believe it I think you have that
talent I think you have that
capabilities most people don't most
people one they don't believe in
themselves enough to actually go off and
chase it by most people don't go off and
explore to find the thing that they have
genius at that they could be Michael
Jordan's not warm before that and
instead you try to photocopy somebody
else's life you try to be the next
somebody no you're a genius let's go
let's chase it down that's why I'm on my
mission I want to solve the world's
biggest problem untapped human potential
I think everybody is that genius and
they either don't know what the thing is
that they should be doing or they don't
believe in themselves hard enough to go
and chase it down so let's work through
those two things whatever can't be fall
into there's gonna be advice that will
help you one you don't know what your
genius said amazing what's the past you
explore you test you try people settle
way too early in life you settle you
settle how do you know if you like sushi
or not until you taste it you don't you
should be trying everything I think
everybody should try to be an
entrepreneur everybody should try to
have a youtube channel everybody should
try to have a podcast everybody should
try to be an accountant like you should
try she pick up everything just to get a
sense say yes to everything once adopt
that mindset mentality we get locked in
to career paths way too soon why because
that's what our parents did because
that's what we want to school for why
you're gonna now
the rest of your life doing something
because you've only tried five different
things and now you're gonna pick like
that's the recipe for disaster
that's why 95 percent of America wakes
up and drives to the job that they hate
you have to try you have to say yes and
don't tie your self-worth to the results
you will suck at the beginning whatever
you first start doing you will suck it
will not work out my first youtube
videos sucked sucked go back watch him
so you can see how bad I was when I
first started my videos I sucked that
was awkward I was nervous I was
introverted it's like we 350 videos
until it wasn't completely embarrassed
by myself three hundred and fifty videos
and so the acid test needs to be do you
like the process do you want to go back
and do it again
you may not have been good at it but you
want to go off and do it again so you
need to say yes to a whole bunch of
things when you don't know what you want
to do in life you need to say yes to
almost everything as long as it falls
within your personal you know values
ethics you're not harming yourself you
know those things you should go off and
try I think you should try it I don't
think you've tried enough if you don't
know what you want to do in life you
have not tried enough and rule number 10
the last only for a very special bonus
clip is don't obsess with perfection
stop trying to be perfect one of the
biggest things that holds entrepreneurs
back is you have an idea in your head
and you want to launch it but you're
afraid to launch anything until it's
perfect you're afraid to put anything
out into the world until you have the
perfect plan the perfect product the
perfect competitive advantage and that
does not exist and the biggest danger of
all is that just stays an idea for you
for the rest of your life that it never
actually gets created because you can
never reach perfection because you're
afraid of releasing the thing out into
the world and so you never will or
everybody who you look up to the people
who've had massive success any
entrepreneur they release something
before it was perfect
the god feedback they adjusted they
listened to it and that became the thing
that propelled into massive success and
so you need to move from that place of
trying to have everything be a hundred
percent perfect before you launch and
just get used to actually creating
actually doing actually putting stuff
out there into the market instead of
sitting on your couch hoping wishing
dreaming planning strategizing but never
actually doing now I've got a special
bonus clip for me on how to be driven
that I really think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point lighting questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one what are
you obsessing over being perfect that
you just need to start number two what
do you need to be more consistent on
that you will put into your calendar
every day this week and number three how
can you better surround yourself with
greatness every single day to be an
entrepreneur you have to be a little
crazy the most successful people in
entrepreneurship in any field they're
crazy you're a little bit crazy you're
on a mission that is crazy that most
people don't understand and listen to
the Elon Musk talk you think he's crazy
I think he's crazy it sounds nuts like
this is 70% chance that you're gonna go
on a one-way ticket to Mars and never
make it there and die there right it's
like and that's what he wants to do and
it's excited to go off and do it it
sounds nuts but that's what you need to
have as an entrepreneur because doing
the thing building the business up that
you want to build will be so difficult
so crazy so challenging that it's that
insane drive that gets you there but you
have to love doing it so much to have
the courage and the passionate energy to
keep going when it's difficult and for
me I want to go to Mars is a serial
percent chance I'm going to Mars but I
love helping entrepreneurs and I could
get lost in helping entrepreneurs I
could spend all day long helping
entrepreneurs and I won't eat and I
won't drink and I'll forget to eat the
bathroom and I'll have a fever and not
even notice it I'll be sitting there
helping entrepreneurs for hours with a
burning fever and not even notice it
because it's the thing that I love doing
and that's what you need to find for
yourself as well
if you want more haven't Carmichael
check out my last top ten rules video
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I hate
spending money till and making money if
you do not have money it's because you
are spending your money on things that
are not making you money